New York could become the first major US
city to cap the number of cars used by
ride-sharing companies after years of
complaints from taxi owners protesters
rallied yesterday ahead of today's
scheduled City Council vote on limiting
companies like uber and lyft Kris Van
Cleave is at Penn Station one of the
commuter hubs here in Manhattan Chris
good morning to you good morning as uber
and lyft have gotten more popular and
really soared in popularity cab drivers
have been lamenting how much harder it
is to make a living back there have been
at least six driver suicides in recent
months some linked to financial woes
it's really driving this legislative
effort to cap uber and lyft now there
are more than 13,500 licensed taxis in
the city but more than a hundred
thousand licensed drivers for ride
hailing apps the proposed legislation
would cap the number of those ride
hailing app drivers at its current level
while the city studies their impact also
being considered is imposing a minimum
wage for drivers that would also be a
first in the nation the mayor and many
drivers support the proposals but uber
and lyft say limiting their drivers will
hurt minority communities that do not
have reliable mass transit they also
claim it would mean longer wait times
and reduce service now all of this comes
as a recent study found ride-sharing
apps are making traffic worse by
encouraging people not to take mass
transit here is a sobering stat about
the sign of the time see this medallion
here on the hood of the cab you need
that to be a New York City cab driver
those used to go for up to a million
dollars apiece now they're worth around
$200,000 Vlad Kris Van Cleave thank you
very much it's a difficult story because
there's arguments to be made on both
sides do indeed